yesterday when we looked at some of the
things said by people who went to the
Michigan Trump rally over the weekend I
missed a clip and it's really like the
most important clip and so in a way it's
good because it won't get all mixed up
in a slurry of insanity we'll just look
at this one clip this is a video clip of
a woman who went to the Trump rally over
the weekend
and she has a really specific
and really complicated conspiracy theory
about election theft and she starts by
saying the election was stolen from
Trump that's not super unique there's
millions of these people who believe
that the election was stolen from Trump
but her explanation is so out there that
listen let's do this let's play the clip
try to listen specifically to each of
the points of the conspiracy and then
we'll talk about them all at once in a
moment the election I believe was stolen
but we know that space force has it all
Trump has all the all the information
it's going to be overturned what do you
think space force has space force is a
military branch of the you know just
like the army that you know all the
military and they literally walk up here
they literally the night of the election
they literally watched the election be
stolen they know they Watermark the
ballots they know exactly what happened
with every ballot they know what fake
ballots all right they saw they knew the
election switches they know what
countries were involved they know they
followed the money they know what every
politician that's been paid off they
know there's um there was 260 000 269
000
sealed indictments but I think it might
even be up to 500 000 sealed indictments
and I believe that we're going to have
an emergency broadcast and the military
is going to come in with martial law
and we are going to be shown eight hours
on eight hours off of videos for seven
days the world and they're going to be
showing us taped
uh tribunals tape confessions
and the world is going to be awakened to
what's really going on with the Deep
state
the election was stolen okay well I mean
that part's common
and I understand what she's saying but
then the rest of it doesn't really make
sense space force and Trump
have all the information all right well
I I don't know why they would have
information but I still follow it it's
going to be overturned well no it's not
I mean listen we're at the next election
already and if Biden were removed for
any reason Kamala Harris becomes VP and
if she's removed then it's Nancy Pelosi
so it that doesn't really make any sense
at all she says the night of the
election space force watched the
election get stolen
what does that mean they watched it like
on TV or they watched it as an
institution she says space force
watermarked the ballots why would space
force do that space force is now
involved in like printing that doesn't
make any sense how would space force
Watermark ballots and then what would
they do with them after that so now I
guess because of the watermarking space
force knows everything including which
countries are involved which is really
like a wow kind of situation she says
politicians have been paid off in space
force knows about it and then it's
completely off the rails and she adds
that there were 269
000 sealed indictments 269
000 people were about to be indicted For
What and space force knew about it why
does space force know about it wouldn't
that be the justice department but maybe
I'm asking too many questions and then
the military would come in with martial
law after an emergency broadcast you
know that's like those beeps that you
hear like this is a test of the
emergency you know the thing they would
you they would do that for hours and
hours with eight hours on and eight
hours off of confessions and tribunals
conducted by whom and when I mean none
of it makes any sense and here's the
real question about this
is this actually let really I want to
hear what you really believe
is this actually a conspiracy theory
that this woman came up with and
understands or is this something that
she misheard or misunderstood and what I
mean by that is I will often get emails
from people
misunderstanding everything I say on
this show a couple weeks ago someone
wrote it and said David I would be
really interested in hearing about where
in Belgium your family is from I've
never said my family is from Belgium I
said I've been to Belgium I said I liked
it I said they have good chocolate I
never said my family's from Belgium
sometimes I say hey if you want a free
membership fill out a form on my website
people email me David I'm asking you to
give me a membership no uh I say I'm
from Argentina and people say wow you're
from Israel yeah okay so if even me
saying really simple stuff leads to this
level of misunderstanding maybe this
entire conspiracy theory is not even
really a conspiracy really a conspiracy
theory she heard from someone else maybe
she misheard it and misunderstood it
either way it's very very scary and I
don't see that turning around anytime
soon and I'm starting to get people mad
at me I mean
for a particular reason people have been
mad at me for a while I'm starting to
get people mad at me because they say
David you need to be proposing solutions
to this problem of radical trumpists I
don't have them guys I'm sorry what I
can tell you is if we want to do
one-on-one it can be hours days weeks to
deprogram someone that's hard to do at
the wholesale level so I don't know that
that's the solution
when it comes to forcing rapid kind of
cultural change
when rapid cultural change has been
forced in the past it's been dictators
it was you know the cultural revolution
in China it was it's bad so that doesn't
seem good I'm not an authoritarian so I
can't say that's the direction we should
go so I don't have an answer yeah fixing
education of course but
I I don't pretend to be the expert with
all the answers I am sort of at my wit's
end with how we deal with these people
and you may know just as much as I do
I'm I happen to be the guy with the mic
but we all need to work together to
figure that out
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
I've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when I use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say I'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up I can delete that virtual
card so I know I'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video